durante su primera estancia a bordo de
la estación espacial en 2016 2017
tomás pérez que realizó experimentos
hizo deporte operaciones de
mantenimiento y tomó fotografías cuando
regresó cuatro años después hizo lo
mismo en el mismo orden solo que tomó
menos fotos en 200 días sea un poco
difícil de creer tuve cinco minutos para
mí tal vez era mi única versión en el
despacho así que quería completar la
alma pero de repente esta vez tal vez me
tocó más de todos para mí solamente para
crear recuerdos de filmar fotografías un
día en el espacio es una sucesión de
tareas perfectamente programadas 90
minutos de deporte diarios para reducir
los efectos de la ingravidez y 36 horas
de experimentos científicos a la semana
en plasma frío para combatir mejor las
bacterias resistentes a los antibióticos
en los cristales de proteínas para
luchar contra determinadas miopatías o
sobre metales antimicrobianos los
propios astronautas son experimentos en
particular para estudiar los efectos de
la ingravidez en el cuerpo humano con el
telón de fondo de la preparación de
viajes más lejanos en particular hacia
marte
el resto del tiempo se dedica al
mantenimiento la estación espacial
internacional es una casa antigua y
siempre ha sido una prioridad para los
astronautas mantenerla en las mejores
condiciones posibles para prolongar su
vida al máximo nos damos cuenta de que
los paneles solares están deteriorando
un poco que la estación está creciendo
que necesitamos un poco más de
electricidad así que vamos a instalar
nuevos paneles solares que se despliegan
antes es un sistema absolutamente
fantástico instalamos tubos enormes que
pesan 350 kilogramos y se desarrollarán
sus salidas bastante ambiciosas y
estaremos trabajando al final de la
estación así que será bastante
emocionante tal salida se prepara con
meses o incluso años de anticipación se
necesitan alrededor de 6 horas para
tener las dosis adecuadas de oxígeno la
presión adecuada purificar la sangre
colgar los cables de seguridad esto no
es hollywood donde estos lanzamientos se
improvisan en unos minutos